[Musik]
servus und herzlich also ich glaube die
waren kurz davor das als musik zu wählen
herzlich zu diesem video und damit zu
einer neuen serie die ich auf meinem
kanal geschaffen hat und zwar ich
bewerte den schnitzer von anderen
youtube-videos ich habe die letzten zehn
jahre damit verbracht videos zu
schneiden und die letzten zweieinhalb
jahre auch explizit damit youtube user
scheinen unter anderem täglich zwei
videos für youtube der winzer durch
wirklich bis ins kleinste detail alles
fein justiert habe die eigene makros und
eigene kleine boots- und programme
geschrieben habe die mir beim schnitt
eben geholfen haben um möglichst
effizient und zeitsparend auf dinge
anzugehen die vielleicht den zuschauer
am ende gar nicht auffallen werden aber
auf einem unterbewussten level
letztendlich darüber entscheiden ob das
video jetzt als angenehm oder als
unangenehm wahrgenommen wird mit dieser
erfahrung werde ich mich heute mal auf
das neueste experiment der csu stürzen
und zwar an die einen eigenen
youtube-kanal hochgezogen mit diesen
werten her dem armin ich habe mich nicht
mit dem inhalt des videos aus einer
setzen zumindest versuche ich das
sondern mich auf den schnitt begrenzen
und diesen anhand der kriterien musik
und soundqualität tempo und sofern
vorhanden wir werden und hinterher noch
eine kleine einschätzung geben was sie
schnitt dauer angeht und noch etwas
erzählen über die wirkung über die
emotionale ebene des ganzen
also hier zählen wir schon die csu will
sich ja eigentlich als eine seriöse und
solide partei darstellt versucht hier
offensichtlich mit diesem jungen und
hinten schnitt auf die junge zielgruppe
auf youtube zu erreichen und an sich ist
es auch gar nicht verkehrt findet
dennoch interessant dass hier am anfang
dann doch ein bisschen viel einbringen
was nicht unbedingt so typisch für eine
politische partei ist aber trotz immer
weiter und herzlich willkommen zur csu
der social media solarzellen in sound
unterstützt und ich werde ab jetzt und
auch braucht die politik also die
arbeiten auch mit uns die arbeiten
zwischen blenden was man jetzt sagen
muss rein qualitativ ist es wirklich bis
jetzt nicht schlecht jemand also da saß
mit sicherheit jemand dran der wirklich
weiß was er macht die ganzen anwendungen
die man sich diesen zauber gearbeitet
die videoqualität ist auch nicht
schlecht dass videos auch nicht schlecht
produziert jede anwendung die hier sehen
können ist auch mit einem gewissen sound
unterlegt zum beispiel dieser ganzen
quatsch effekte es wird ja ganz youtube
mich auch mit uns gearbeitet ich gehe
mal davon aus dass da wirklich einer der
ansatz der sich mit der thematik
auskennst weil die qualität stimmt auf
jeden fall zwingen er weiß auf jeden
fall was man trägt er ist mit sicherheit
ein sehr guter vater beziehungsweise
video endet
und ich könnte mir gut vorstellen dass
diese person nicht unbedingt aus dem
youtube kontext kommt und nicht
unbedingt aus der youtube szene stammt
und vielleicht auch noch gar nicht so
viele tube videos geschnitten hat
erdogan vorahnung wahrscheinlich aber
aus einem anderen gebiet wie ich jetzt
einmal vermuten würde
und denen wurde dann von wer auch immer
das produziert gesagt mach das mal
möglichst hipp und ja das ist ihm an
sich auch gelungen insofern ist dennoch
bis jetzt schon ein bisschen überladen
lima ikone greta abramowitsch hohenberg
es wird hier sehr viel mehr sound
gearbeitet ist sie mit ich weiß dass
nichts zählen kann aber jetzt sind
eigentlich schon - dieses also hier auch
dieser clip effekte sind glitschig den
werden dürfte sich so ziemlich durch das
ganze video
der ist vom aufwand nicht so krass ich
gehe mal von außen einfach einen
priester drauf geklatscht und sound
runde gelegt so wie ich es hier auch
gerade mache ich finde was prinzipiell
schon cool wenn es nicht über unbedingt
überladen ist aber die frage ist halt
übermittelt die richtige botschaft und
hier wird sie haben einen ernsthaften
thema ausgesetzt und deswegen weiß ich
nicht ob das jetzt die richtige wahl ist
diese geschäftigen dem ausmaß zu
verwenden und von einem psychologischen
standpunkt des schnitts insofern da ja
schon quasi mit einem sound dieses bild
rein gewischt wurde dann noch hinterher
diesen blick drauf zu machen glaube ich
tut dem ganzen nicht wirklichen gefallen
klimaneutral
hier wird das mini game der csu auf
jeden fall richtig auf ein neues level
gehoben mit dieser cricket mit der
grille die hier fröhlich durch ziert
klimaneutral
also ja das so an sich könnte man jetzt
natürlich cool finden dass seine partei
überhaupt teams integriert in ihren
videos abgesehen davon gebe es an der
stelle auch wirklich sehr sehr viele
passende remis
generell als stilmittel sehr viele songs
und prinzipiell bin ich dafür youtube
videos auf seite wichtig ich benutze ich
selbst also oft weil die einfach das
ganze auf locker ein bisschen
dynamischer machen und da fällt also das
heißt fällt sich auf da wirkt eben eine
andere ebene statische kamera trotzdem
ein bisschen trotzdem bisher mehr
interaktiv das einfach sich was rührt
ich weiß persönlich noch nicht ganz was
ich davon halten soll dass die nicht auf
die ihn auf den protagonisten hier
zentriert gesund haben
sondern hier einmal ihn auf der linken
seite haben und dann hier ihnen einmal
plötzlich auf der rechten seite haben
wenn ich persönlich ein bisschen komisch
ich prinzipiell so man immer auf das
gesicht drauf und nicht jetzt irgendwie
hier in die decke oder hier ein sofa
finde ich sehr interessant
anja mal neutral wäre greta einfach in
die usa geflogen hätte sie und ich finde
deutlich weniger finde ich die musik
bisschen laut ich finde sie nicht
unbedingt also die aktuell läuft bin ich
nicht unpassend sondern einfach ein
bisschen zu laut nehmen einfach den
kläger ist besseres klima also hat
natürlich mit der qualität des videos zu
tun den schriftzug schön an und für sich
nur ob das jetzt ein passendes niemals
an der stelle ist dann geschmacks
hier macht das hier gemacht der sie zum
beispiel sind den ich vorhin kritisiert
hat weil dadurch kann man nämlich obwohl
man herr 1 und hat man dadurch auf der
linken hat er mehr platz für jetzt zum
beispiel dieses grüne logo deswegen ist
er so nie an der stelle das hier mit der
zweiten kamera und dem schwarz-weißen
mittel finde ich prinzip manchmal
schlecht farblich gestaltet übrigens
auch sehr gut das ganze wenn auch mit
diesem schwarz weiß wenn ich farblich
prinzipiell aber sehr schön abgestimmt
weiß ich jetzt nicht ob das absicht
wie gesagt ohne aufenthalt anzugehen
finde ich diese anwendung die animation
von diesem verboten schild finde ich
cool gemacht nicht zu unserer offenen
und freien gesellschaft gemacht zum
beispiel sehr viel sinn er redet erst
was und dann bringe quasi den contra
argumente oder im gegensatz und beginnt
diesen gegensatz auch noch mit einem
sehr harten ton und da ist so ein
suchender der kommt jetzt natürlich
darüber wie man jetzt 10 wird gehört das
etwa nicht zu unserer offenen und freien
gesellschaft ich dachte jemand schwarz
rot gold steht da macht das auf jeden
fall so viel sinn
mit extremisten gegen extremismus
demonstrieren
[Musik]
und deswegen an die augen trieb
hier ist mir vielleicht sogar ein
schnitt fehler aufgefallen
wohin wir sehen jetzt gerade dass die
kamera quasi auf ihn rein kommt und dann
anstatt anstelle dass sie still bleibt
sie noch mal nach oben und nach unten
und ich bin fast 100 prozent sicher dass
das nicht an dem kameramann lag weil die
kamera stand hier auf einem stativ sein
dass der mann keine flüchtigkeitsfehler
unterlaufen ist was absolut nichts
schlimmes passiert wir sehen hier dem
hintergrund dass die kamera eben hier
obwohl es eigentlich schon rein gesund
ist und der so nicht mehr weitergeht die
position immer noch ein stückchen
animiert wird und ab dürfte tja aber die
ganzen schnitte und die laute also die
haben sich die jugendlichen musiker
ausgewählt hat dass sie nicht irgendwie
dubstep oder so eingebrannt haben
[Musik]
servus und herzlich
also ich glaube die waren kurz davor das
als musik zu wählen er fängt quasi damit
an zu erzählen was die csu dann alles
erreicht hat jetzt den ersten schliff
und alle anderen sachen werde natur
gestohlen und sowas benutzt man
natürlich relativ oft oder wie ich
benutze was natürlich relativ oft um
gewisse sachen aber lustiger zu machen
wenn man einfach lange texte rede die
eigentlich nicht wirklich interessanten
aber werden sie trotzdem so ein bisschen
drin lassen will hier so ein bisschen
das falsche zeichen wenn man eben quasi
seine stärken gerade hervorrufen möchte
die abschaffung des soli auf den weg
gebracht wenn also mal wieder hier weiß
nicht ob das musikalisch so geteilt
wurde aber auf jeden fall ist der
musikalische höhepunkt dann auch diese
pointe von dem was er sagen wird im
detail ist was an und für sich nicht
schlecht ist das ist nicht schlecht
komplette bewertung in der kategorie
qualität würde ich den dingen eine
glatte nicht mögen erzählen aber eine 9
auf jeden fall geben erzählt aber immer
sehr schwer zu erreichen aber
prinzipiell von der qualität fand ich es
nicht schlecht qualität des tons war
sehr gut die schnitte haben jetzt kein
knacken gab ball oft ist es beim
schneiden so wenn man harten schnitt
macht dass man zwischen zwei clubs
ebenso ein knacken hört wie in diesem
beispiel junge zielgruppe auf youtube zu
erreichen und an sich ist es an sich ist
schon an sich ist wogegen man dann quasi
so eine kleine überblendung beim ton
machen kann was dieses knacken eben
unterbindet dann hört sich so an bächen
und teichen und ansieht bereichen und an
sie das wissen viele unerfahrene leute
auf jeden fall ich aber derjenige der
das geschehen hat er war auf jeden fall
ein profi zum thema musik und tanz habe
ich ein freund schon angemerkt
das nicht ein bisschen zu laut hat die
musik einfach und die sounds fand ich
sowieso sehr sehr oft einfach nicht
stimmig ist aber vielleicht auch einmal
eine geschmackssache zudem ist die musik
natürlich nicht unbedingt der
authentischste für die csu auch wenn sie
sich ein bisschen wie bränden will für
die jüngeren leute muss ich dann leider
bei musik und sounds hier nur eine drei
von zehn geben und was mich angeht
sofern es denn welche war nicht wenn ich
kommentiere ich bin da kann ich ja auch
nicht mehr als ein von zehn punkten
geben was das tempo angeht fand ich am
anfang echt schrecklich was aber viel zu
schnell und hektisch geschnitten ist
aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
hab's mit ungefähr 45 mal angeguckt und
bei jedem mal angeguckt habe ich mich
ein bisschen mehr daran gewöhnt dass es
so krass ist deswegen hier beim tempo
jetzt sechs von zehn auch wenn ich weiß
dass viele leute da noch schlechter ab
geben wird so zur schnitt dauer des
videos also an und für sich haben hier
ein video was auf den ersten blick für
jemanden der jetzt vielleicht nicht so
viel mit schneiden zu tun als sehr
aufwändig aussehen kann und es kann auch
wirklich dass er aufwendig sein und es
hängt einfach davon ab hat derjenige
presets benutzt hat derjenige der das
geschnitten hat schon öfter in diesem
schnitt viel geschnitten und hat quasi
ein größeres repertoire an effekten und
presets und templates dir dafür schon
einfach aus dem ärmel geschüttelt hat
und hier schon auf dem pc hat er unseren
benutzen konnte wo der musste er sich
die ah selber erstellen was ich nicht
glaube oder b musste er sich die erst
noch heraus suchen oder c hatte er die
eben schon auf dem pc und je nachdem ob
die selber erstellt hat was ich nicht
glaube auch nicht empfehlen würde hat
wirklich sehr sehr lange gedauert oder
aber die eben schon auf dem pc hatte
also wenn er die ich jetzt alle schon
auf dem pc hatte und quasi klare ansagen
von denen bekommen hat und jetzt nicht
wirklich viele korrektur schleifen
da waren und wenn quasi alles möglichst
gut gelaufen ist kann ich mir vorstellen
dass man in so ein video auf jeden fall
innerhalb von zwei stunden gut durch
schneiden kann diese grippe effekte zb
jetzt einfach mal um euch zu
demonstrieren dann könnte ich jetzt hier
zum beispiel einfach mal glitsch in
meinen effekten suchen und das sind
alles effekte jetzt die hat man normal
nicht die hatte ich mir selber irgendwie
entweder gekauft oder kostenlos
heruntergeladen kann jetzt einfach mal
einen drauf schauen wir mal die
kitschfrei und dann hätte sie haben wir
hier einen wunderschönen blick effekt ja
davon gibt's einfach hier jede menge die
ich hier habe und die kann man immer
drauf ziehen und das funktionieren die
auch direkt die ganzen zooms die die
gemacht haben sind natürlich zwar
einerseits viele zooms andererseits ist
es aber auch nur ein video das fünf
minuten gehen und jetzt nicht zehn wie
die meisten und youtube wichtiges und
dementsprechend würde ich hier sage man
könnte es auch in zwei stunden machen
glaube ich aber in dem fall nicht
unbedingt ich kann mir erforschen das
ist für denjenigen das geschnittene
neuigkeit war kann mir vorstellen dass
wir hier mit der csu bzw generell mit
einer politischen vorteil leitenden
ziemlich anstrengend empfunden haben der
halt einfach vielleicht hohe ansprüche
hat oder so und man dementsprechend
mehrere feedback schleifen durchläuft
und dann es auf einfach hier vielleicht
einen ganzen arbeitstag für denjenigen
der das geschnitten hat beanspruchen
kann zu sechs sieben acht stunden so
wenn ihr jetzt auch so absolut geil
schneiden leuchtet wie die csu und auch
möchte dass die leute die auf video
gucken einfach epilepsie christen weil
so viele effekte drin sind dann kann ich
euch meinen schnittkurs empfehlen da
bringe ich euch quasi das schneiden bald
innerhalb von zwei stunden videomaterial
das ihr euch so oft angucken könnt wie
ihr möchtet und so langsam wir möchten
dem ich die ganzen details des
schneidens mit von mir pro erläutert was
auch ein kommentar anfänger der noch nie
im schnitt sogar angefasst hat verstehen
wird aber auch einigermaßen volk
gestellt wird dann auch einige sachen
daraus lernen können nur ein kompletter
profit da wird natürlich nicht über den
glauben kannst gehabt also wie gesagt
wenn ihr lust habt stein zu sein wie die
csu
oder wie ich dann den link in der
beschreibung ab und zu guter letzt wenn
ihr mich auf dieser reise begleiten
möchtet könnt ihr das auf instagram post
die regelmäßig bilder oder japan üblich
am besten auf youtube dann sehen wir uns
nämlich auch beim nächsten mal wieder
und in dem sinn hat magst du bis dahin
[Musik]